Expand your horizons with your LK-150
knitting machine by using skinny yarn.
Use sock yarn on your LK-150?
Sure!
You might be surprised at the results you
can get by using different yarns with your
machine.
Hi, I'm Sue, the voice and the
hands behind the Knit it Now videos.
For over 10 years, we've been helping
knitters just like you learn more about
their knitting machines
and yarn and have success
with their machine knitting.
Let's take a look as we play with some
skinny yarn and get some surprising
results.
The terms used to describe yarn weights
are really subjective and regional, but
let's use the craft yarn counsel's
numbered standards for today's
conversation.
Often LK-150 knitters use worsted weight
yarn, a medium or a number 4 yarn.
This is a very common weight used by hand
knitters, and it's part of the appeal of
the LK-150.
Knitters who are new to machine
knitting, are comfortable with this yarn.
It hand knits on a size 7 or
9 US hand knitting needle.
Now, depending on the yarn, machine
knitters would knit this at a tension 6 to
8 on the LK-150.
Now something to keep in mind.
Again, these terms and these
categories are very subjective.
A lot depends on the fiber
and the twist of the yarn.
These two yarns are categorized as a
4 or a medium, but they ended up very
differently.
One is more loosely
twisted than the other.
With that being said, have you tried
a lighter weight yarn on your machine?
There are very few hard and
fast rules in machine knitting.
But there are a few things to consider.
I'm going to knit a get-acquainted swatch
and put my machine through its paces with
this yarn.
I bet you're asking what's
a get-acquainted swatch?
It's a way of determining.
What tension you like to knit a yarn at?
What are the results at a specific tension
with a specific yarn that you like?
This is a skill that you need to learn
to play with different yarns and your
knitting machine.
First, consider your mask tension.
The yarn I'm using is Yeoman's Sport and
it's actually quite fine, and I would
consider it more of a sock weight yarn.
So there is that terminology again,
potato, potatoe, Sock Weight, DK, four
-ply, eight-ply.
When I thread up my mast, I immediately
noticed that said, at tension 5.
The yarn was slack and the take-up
spring was standing straight up.
It wasn't doing its job
of tensioning the yarn.
I turned the dial down to 1, I tightened
it all the way and this feels better as I
thread up my carriage
and get started knitting.
The next thing to consider
is the carriage tension.
This controls the stitch size.
I went ahead and cast on at about a
tension 3 so I could just easily get some
stitches on the needles.
But I'll start knitting
my swatch at tension 1.
Knit a few rows.
The machine is knitting the stitches well.
No loops or struggles.
The carriage isn't hard to push.
So I know after that first row or two,
that tension 1 is possible and I'll
continue knitting a few inches, but I
can tell right away that the knitting is
really tight.
Moving up to tension 2, I'll knit a few
inches and the knitting that the fabric is
starting to feel a whole lot better.
Move up to tension 3 and
I'm really liking tension 3.
Tension 4 started to get sloppy
and not what I would want.
Now, this is again, very, very subjective.
You may love this yarn attention 4 or
5 and it would create a beautiful, very
drapey fabric.
But for the project I have in mind,
tension 4 or 5 probably won't work for me.
After I dropped this, get acquainted
swatch off the machine, I dressed it,
which means I washed it steamed, it, did
everything to it that I will do to my
final garment,
and then this now will be the final
test to determine what I really like.
Now that I've determined what I like, the
next step is to knit a proper gauge swatch
and establish the gauge for
my project with this yarn.
I'm not going to use this
get acquainted swatch.
I need to knit a proper gauge swatch
that I can get an accurate gauge.
The bottom line behind this whole
experiment, can I use skinny yarns on
LK-150?
Yes.
Well, I'd be happy with the results.
Absolutely.
And I've opened up a wide range of
possibilities for using different yarns
with my knitting machine.